what if these paintings just pop them
off and some begin dimension and the
same type of camera work that you see in
the original films that would be a very
inspired animated series hey youtubers
it's Charlie and Disney is getting ready
to premiere a new trailer for the Star
Wars rebels cartoon remember that's the
cartoon that's following up from the
Clone Wars so I wanted to do a video
explaining everything we know so far
what the characters are who the actors
are and what they're going to be doing
on the show if you remember last year
disney announced that they were buying
Lucasfilm for more money than you or I
will ever see in our entire lives i
think it was like four billion dollars
which actually seems like a bargain
compared to how much money that Star
Wars is made over the years but they
announced as a result they were getting
rid of the Clone Wars after five seasons
to make way for a new post Disney
cartoon and that was Star Wars rebels so
a lot of Clone Wars fans really hated
the idea a lot of people love the idea
of a new star wars cartoon though and
they are keeping on the original team
from the Clone Wars or at least most of
the people that worked on the Clone Wars
the creative people so I think it will
be really exciting to see and they have
released some concept art which you can
see here let's talk about what the show
is all about the show is taking place in
that 19 year gap between Revenge of the
Sith and a new hope that 19 year period
of the dark times so they'll still be
Jedi on the show but the Empire will
basically be hunting them down this is
the original team from the Clone Wars i
think the animation style will look a
little bit like the Clone Wars but
obviously it's a totally different
cartoons so don't expect it to look
exactly the same but here's where we
should get really really excited so
here's the voice cast and you may
recognize some of these people so first
things first legend of korra fans this
one's for you stephen j bloom the voice
of a mon will be playing one of the
characters one of the main characters so
this is gonna be so amazing obviously
he's a voice actor that's done hundreds
of hundreds of cartoons a lot of people
might remember him as the voice of spike
from cowboy bebop so I'm really excited
about that so that just alone by itself
gets me excited for the show then
there's Freddie Prinze jr. which
everybody knows obviously David Oyelowo
who a lot of people might not recognize
right away he is going to be in
Christopher Nolan's new interstellar
movie that's gonna be Christopher
Nolan's new sci-fi movies so he's
actually a really great actor but he
does mostly in real life stuff he
doesn't do as much animation voiceover
then there's venice marshall which you
may recognize as the voice of black
widow from Avengers earth Mightiest
Heroes and then the other actor is Tim
grey who you might not recognize but
he's done some other small nickel
loading stuff but seriously am on is
going to be doing Star Wars how awesome
is that high fives for everyone high
fives all around I'll just leave my hand
here you can have five it so like I said
the show's going to be during the dark
time so there won't be a lot of Jedi on
the show they'll still be hunting them
down so what I think is going to end up
happening is is that the show will
mostly follow non Jedi characters and
characters from the Empire their hunting
Jedi down on a ship called the ghost
I'll talk about that in just a second
but when Jedi do show up I think it'll
just be in cameos and it'll be played by
guest actors though I don't think any of
these main cast members that I just
talked about will be Jedi
let's take a quick pull though would you
watch a show knowing full well that
there would be no Jedi on it personally
I totally what there's so many aspects
of star wars and the mythology is so
deep you can do a show just about
anything just about bounty hunters just
about people in the Empire just about
rebels just about huts you can basically
pick almost any alien species and do
something based on them but since this
is Disney's first show after buying Star
Wars and Lucasfilm I think they're going
to totally play it safe and we will see
Jedi on the show periodically I don't
blame them if I spent four billion
dollars on something I'd want a couple
sure bits to let's talk a little bit
about what we do know about the show so
far we have seen some mock-ups of the
ship so we do have some basic concept
art it's a Corellian freighter a
modified curling afraid or just like the
Falcon and I kind of think that's the
mental leap they want people to make
like oh it's the Millennium Falcon but
it's a different ship but it does have
some of the same features it has the gun
turret it has a lounge crew quarters the
cockpit they said is going to look a lot
like a b22 bomber so here's some
pictures of that but I think it's going
to be really exciting and I'm excited to
see the animation in the trailer they're
going to release next week so I think
we're going to learn a little bit more
about the actual characters they haven't
released too many details we really only
know who the voice actors are we don't
know exactly who the character is going
to be other than they're going to be
traveling on this ship that Ghost as
opposed to the clone wars that delve
really deep into Star Wars mythology and
existing characters or pre-existing
characters I think that Star Wars rebels
is actually going to introduce a lot of
new original characters but like I said
Disney playing it safe I think we'll see
a lot of characters that we already know
on the show at least in cameos or
reference since the show isn't going to
premiere until fall next year like
around this time it's going to be a
while before we see a full episode or
even part of an episode they might bring
a few things but they do tend to save
their best stuff for their own
convention in d23 so if we do get to see
a full episode and I think that they
probably will screen the pilot episode
next year at d23 obviously i went to d23
this past year I'll go again next year
so don't worry I'll do a full review
non-spoilery and spoilery for people who
don't mind spoilers but i'll be doing
tons more Star Wars videos for rebels
and episode 7 be sure to subscribe to
get them next week remember we have that
trailer coming so i'll do a video for
that too whenever it comes out but let
me know what you want to know most about
the show do
mostly about the characters mostly about
the story or mostly about the technical
aspects like the ships are going to be
using and the technology obviously this
is that kind of that in-between time so
there can be swinging lightsabers around
but there should be a lot of really cool
ships and planets are going to visit as
always be sure to like and share this
video using the tools below it totally
helps me out I totally give extra high
fives for anyone that shares my videos
thank you so much in the meantime while
we wait for that trailer you can click
here to watch all my other Star Wars
related videos I'll be sure to update
the annotation as soon as the trailer
drops so that'll point to that when it
comes and you can click here to watch
all my other Legend of Korra videos
remember I'm on on Star Wars high fives
for everyone thank you so much
you